as we've talked about in multiple videos
some of the early civilizations we have
found have been around river valleys and
that is no coincidence because some of
the first agriculture emerged around
river valleys and the agriculture
supported higher population densities
and more sedentary populations and
allowed for more specialization and
we've talked about several of these the
Egyptian the ancient Egyptians around
the Nile River the ancient Mesopotamians
around the Tigris and Euphrates and now
we're going to talk about the ancient
ancient civilization around the Indus
River the Indus River runs mostly in
modern-day Pakistan and that's why it's
called the Indus Valley Civilisation in
this valley civilization civilization
it's also sometimes referred to as the
Harappan civilization which was the
first site where they found evidence of
this fairly extensive civilization now
to get ourselves to get ourselves
acquainted in time this shows when when
archaeologists historians consider to be
the the main part of the Harappan
civilization there's evidence that
people had basic villages civilizations
agriculture here as far back as 7000 BCE
and that's just based on the evidence we
have today but when people refer to the
Indus Valley Civilisation in particular
they're usually starting around 3300 BCE
and orange right over here this is the
early period or you could say the early
Indus Valley Civilisation now some of
the biggest structures and the pieces of
technology that have been discovered
have been right over here which is often
referred to as the mature mature period
for the Indus Valley Civilisation and
then it goes into decline we'll talk
about why it might have gone into
decline although we're not really sure
and this is called the late now to put
it in context relative to these other
civilizations remember the ancient
Sumerians were starting to be quite I
guess you could say civilized by about
this period you start having a lot of
intermingling between the Akkadian
and the sumerians as you get into the
late third millennium
that's when you have the Empire of
Sargon the great the Akkadian Empire as
you get to the end of this mature period
right over here this is close to the or
around the time of Hammurabi the
Babylonian Empire and in Egypt if you go
back to around 2500 around this time
that's when the pyramids were built and
you have the Egyptian kings these God
kings that were ruling for most of this
period right over here and as we'll see
there was actually we believe a good bit
of cultural interchange between these
significant civilisations now just to
appreciate how extensive this Indus
Valley Civilisation was I will show you
this map and this map it's a zoomed-in
of that region around the Indus Valley
that I just showed you this is a map of
most of Pakistan here and these red
squares are places where they have found
evidence of the civilization the first
place was Harappa right over here the
Punjab region of Pakistan and that's why
it's called the Harappan civilization
but as you can see it's much more than
just around Harappa the largest site is
at mohenjo-daro right we're going to
sind the region of Pakistan and it's
believed that as many as 40,000 people
lived in that city that we now are that
site that we now call mohenjo-daro and
so far we have discovered over 1,000
sites in this area and we believe that
as many as 5 million people might have
been part of the civilization another
reason why we think it is a civilization
and not and let me actually keep
scrolling around so you appreciate the
extent of it their sites and mainly many
in Pakistan that you see here there's
also quite a few in modern-day
modern-day India right over here so it's
an extensive network of these sites and
the reason why we think it's one
civilization or at least a connected
culture is that you find a lot of
standardization you find sounder
standardization and their weights and
measures in fact they have a unit of
measurement that's as small as 1.6 mm
and the reason why that's important is
you wouldn't create a unit of
measurement of one point six millimeters
unless you knew how to use something
unless you know how to make things that
precise and one of the things that they
made that precise are things like their
structures they had these standard
bricks and these these brick this brick
size and many of these symbols that they
use were found throughout these sites
which said we don't know whether they
were controlled by one ruler or one
Emperor but there was definitely a lot
of cultural interchange to the point
that they were using the same sized
bricks they were using the same symbol
they were using the same units of
measurement and also as you can imagine
having a unit of measurement that
precise that that that small implies
that there were great builders and the
evidence we find today says yes they
were this is a picture of the site at
mohenjo-daro and modern-day Sindh
Pakistan and you can see how tight this
brickwork is even by modern standards
this is quite good you need to think how
many of things we would build would last
5,000 years and this good being exposed
to the environment so they think this
was a public bath you see a citadel in
the background we've discovered
defensive structures perhaps most
impressively there's a most impressive
there's sewage systems they think houses
had wells water so this is a
technologically advanced civilization
especially for that time in many ways
more advanced than the other
civilizations the contemporary
civilizations that we had talked about
here are some examples of their of their
sculpture or of their art this is this
one right over here is a picture it's
called dancing girl but she's not
dancing what they think that might be
her profession but it's all speculation
by archaeologists today this they
believe is a this called priest-king
once again it's all speculation this is
an example of the types of seals they
made this is their jewelry once again
this is quite intricate jewelry and this
jewelry was not just discovered in
archeological digs in these various
sites there's evidence of there's
evidence of their jewelry as far as
Mesopotamia and digs there and they
believed that there was actually
a very active maritime trade network
between these areas there's jewelry
discovered in these Indus Valley
civilizations that were based on shells
from the Arabian Peninsula they have
materials from China
so there's materials from other parts of
India so once again a very very
extensive trade network these
civilizations would have known about
them but as we said they were extremely
they seemed somewhat organized even
though we can't read their writing in
fact I have some examples of their
writing here and you might notice so
this is examples of their writing and
you might notice there this has turned
into a somewhat infamous symbol now
because of the Nazis this is a swastika
but the floss tikka was one of the
symbols they use it's a symbol and
Hinduism it's considered a symbol of
good luck it's something that the the
Nazis kind of usurped and turn it into a
very negative thing but it does show
this connection between that Indus
Valley or that Harappan civilization and
modern cultures that are in India and
things like the Hindu religion although
once again we do not know a ton about
their religion because we their language
hasn't survived and we have we that we
cannot decipher their actual writing but
because of their organization and the
consistency a relative consistency
amongst these different sites that are
so far flowing this is a lot this is
large distance even on modern tape terms
but especially if we're talking about
four or five thousand years ago because
of that we think that okay there must
have been at least decent and government
administration or organization at a
city-state level although we're unsure
whether there was a connected Empire
whether you had an organization beyond
that or they all just decided to to take
each other's standards and and and
symbols and brick sizes and things like
that now one of the the key mysteries of
the Indus Valley Civilisation is why did
it end it seemed to be the thriving the
thriving civilization that's perhaps the
most extensive one in other videos I
talk about right now the oldest wheel
was discovered in Mesopotamia but some
people think that the wheel
might have been used even earlier in the
Indus Valley Civilisation I talked about
this period as early as 3300 BCE but
there's evidence that the civilization
the civilization started much earlier
and the site right over here in Maher
gar right over here in Pakistan they
think that humans were having simple
villages and Agriculture's early there's
evidence is early 7000 BCE and that site
was discovered just in 1974 we might
discover things that take us even
further in the past and when you have a
civilization that was around for so long
if there were people there's early 7000
BC we're talking about it was there for
thousands of years but all of a sudden
it starts to cook the decline there's
evidence of less and less trade going on
the less and less sophistication and
then it ends and it's one of the
mysteries of history of archaeology
today why did this Indus Valley
Civilisation end some of the older
theories worse maybe it was a foreign
invasion maybe some of the ancestors of
the modern Indians invaded maybe they
assimilated in somehow more current
theories don't think that was the case
they think it might be some form of
climate change that some of the
important rivers dried up made the
agriculture much harder some people
think it might have been a natural
disaster it might have been a flood of
some kind but we just don't know or the
people for some reason decided to leave
died migrate through maybe other parts
of the region but needless to say it was
a significant civilization and we're
just scratching the surface of what we
know about it we know a lot and we know
it was impressive even though we can't
read their script and we don't know as
much about it as we know about ancient
Mesopotamia and the ancient Egyptians
but signs are that as more time passes
we'll realize that it was more and more
sophisticated and impressive than maybe
even appreciate today